good morning everyone I'm wondering if
we should just get started here um there
thank you everybody for clicking over
from the go-to meeting site we realized
quite quickly that the go-to meeting
site wasn't going to be adequate enough
to hold everybody who is coming in and
I'll go over and I'll make an
announcement on that site here in just a
moment I wanted to not delay anything
further because we want to hear from
certainly hear from dr. amusement we
want to be able to hear from dr. borne
um and and others so I want to get
things underway
without further ado I'm curious if
Michele Dunne would like to make any
sort of announcements before we begin
fantastic so I think we'll just turn
things over to dr. mark mucin from
Stanford University who's going to be
speaking on the introduction to big data
and the data life cycle
dr. Bourn is available though before
hands perhaps that's how we want to
begin yep I'm here
thanks jack let me just say a couple of
things so welcome to the first lecture
in the big data to knowledge
fundamentals and data science series
it's clearly very exciting we've got a
large virtual turnout I guess I would
say I'd have to say good day because I
don't know where what time zone you're
in and where you're coming from but
thank you for joining us I think this is
already with C is going to be a very
successful initiative so I'm the
Associate Director for data science at
the National Institutes of Health and I
coordinate the big data to knowledge
initiative we've put together this
program of a series of lectures that
sort of collectively covered data
science and clearly there's a lot of
interest in this and they're going to
occur once a week for the next nine
months
so hopefully you worry if you're on this
presumably you have a schedule already
before I introduce mark I just wanted to
thank Jack and the training Coordination
Center for taking the lead in organizing
this series and Michelle done in
our own offices Stella are putting these
things together and getting things going
and so it's a joint collaboration
between the training coordination center
the center's coordination center and the
NIH so let me now quickly introduce mark
I won't give him a long introduction
although he deserves one but he's the
kind of guy who will be happy with a
short one and thank you for mark for
setting the stage for the whole series
and also of course being involved in the
planning the series that's that's really
much appreciated I've known mark for a
long time and he's done some really
stellar work and I'm not going to go
into all the detail but let me just
quickly say he's currently a professor
of biomedical informatics at Stanford as
well as the director of the Stanford
center for biomedical informatics
research his risk his research covers a
lot of areas notably intelligent systems
reusable ontology is metadata for data
publication biomedical decision support
he's been recognized in in various ways
including the recipient of the Donald
Lindberg Award for innovation
informatics and American Medical
Informatics Association elected to the
American College of medical informatics
and the Association of American
physicians and it's a founding co-editor
and chief of the journal Applied
ontology so mark thank you for agreeing
to kick this off we're all very much
looking forward to what you have to say
thanks again and thank you so I'm real
grateful this is rather an awesome
responsibility to give the first lecture
in this series and I'm actually very
excited to do so because I think the
lectures that will follow me will be
even perhaps more more interesting than
this general overview but I think it's
very important to sort of frame what
we'll be doing over the next few weeks
and to give you a general introduction
to data science and and where we are
heading and where the field is heading
so as you know this is the first lecture
of a whole series has been put together
by the bd2k training coordinating center
with help from the Centers coordinating
Center with carbonite staff and
a little bit of help from me and we're
very very excited to be able to give you
a whole series of lectures and data
science that will obviously be very
exciting this quarter and then we'll
continue to the rest of the year what I
want to do this morning is to foreshadow
a lot of the things that you'll hear
about from the other speakers and can
give you in a sense for why there's so
much excitement about data science and
why this field is so important and it
clearly is important because the world
is changing we think in terms of data in
ways which we probably never did before
we used to think of data as sort of the
side effects of scientific research and
now we recognize that data are
first-class entities of themselves that
also require careful consideration
careful thought careful planning and
what I want to do this morning is to
give you a sense for what some of that
planning needs to be in order to get the
most out of the kinds of data that are
acquires consequence of scientific
investigation a lot of stuff is floating
around the web about how the world is
changing because of data there was a
recent piece on PBS that made claims
such as all the data processes that we
did in the last two years is more than
all the data processing we did in the
last three thousand years or we're now
being exposed to as much information in
a single day as our 15th century
ancestors were exposed to in their
entire lifetime and every two days human
race is now generating as much data as
we as we generated from the dawn of
humanity through the year of 2000
through 2003 these these are obviously
breathtaking sentences frankly no one
quite knows where the data that support
these particular sentences but it gives
you a sense for why the world is
recognizing that the onslaught and
information around us clearly is
changing the way we live qualitatively
and biomedicine we have the onset of the
genomics revolution which has led to
more data than anyone could ever imagine
in clinical medicine we have the advent
of electronic health records whose data
are now being mined in all kinds of ways
where we recognize that we may not
always have the skills that we need in
order to appreciate the kinds of
information there that are coming around
us in biomedicine the room big data of
course is what's on everyone's lips and
at the same time it's a word that has a
lot of overload has a lot of
associations made with it I'm not going
to try to define Big Data intentionally
I think that's kind of hard to do but
it's very easy to describe it in terms
of its characteristics and the three
that are often mentioned are the idea of
data volume just a lot of data velocity
the way in which data comes at us very
quickly and variety the heterogeneity
and the data that that we're acquiring
and to that people will often add the
idea that there's a question of veracity
we get loss of data we don't always know
the truth value of the data that we that
we received and volume was not what I
meant to say here but yes I will
remember the 15 years later this is just
a slide from IBM trying to sort of
summarize what they believe being the
way in which they view big data and I
said I think it's important not to
necessarily look at all of the examples
that they give on their slide but to
make it clear how much the Big Data
revolution is affecting not only what we
do in science but also what's happening
in industry and we see that throughout
society there's this increasing desire
to be able to identify where they are
coming from to deal with data and to be
able to prepare for the fact that in the
future in the amount of data we deal
with we will even be greater and
although it's easy to think about big
data and emphasize the word big and
think about quantitative differences I
think what makes us what makes it
important in data science is a
recognition that data because of the way
they are changing our world are thinking
things qualitatively suddenly were in a
situation where our servers no more
longer can store all the data that we
use to store in a single place and we
think about news Newton solutions both
in terms of hardware and the kinds of
data systems that those hardware support
we have thinking about new algorithms
because we suddenly can't process data
in ones and once in one sitting we
suddenly have to recognize that because
of the volume and velocity and
everything else about the data we need
to have algorithms that can keep up with
them and probably most important
although not nothing that gets a lot of
press is that we're moving into an era
where we can't get our arms around the
data we can't look at the data we can't
really understand intuitively whether
the data all mean and so there's a need
to be able to deal with the fact that
our cognitive ability is strained
because without the ability to deal with
the visualization of data and to get an
intuitive understanding of data we often
have to go truly on the basis of our
algorithms which obviously limits our
ability to develop intuition about the
work that we're doing this is a slide
that was generated by by Forrester
Research trying to identify what are all
the various technologies that are
required to manage the data revolution
I'm not going to go through the slide in
detail because frankly a lot of the
stuff that's on this line is going to be
handled in the talks that you're going
to be hearing in this series coming up
but it was important to emphasize from
this slide is the fact that Forrester
believes we've had significant success
in a lot of the infrastructure needed to
manage big data and what's interesting
is that all of this big successes happen
very rapidly and the time to reach the
next phase whatever that next phase
might be in each one of these areas it's
not that long and so as far as the
infrastructure is concerned far as to it
argued that we're making progress
and certainly when it comes to
biomedicine and IH recognized a couple
years ago the importance of addressing
the big data challenges that are facing
us and biomedicine and as you know the
creation of the big data to knowledge
initiative and this seminar series which
is part of that initiative has been a
major undertaking on the part of the NIH
to be able to move I ology and
into the next arrow and so I think
there's a lot of excitement it's a lot
of height but there's also a lot of
progress that's being made in this area
and that's obviously the important stuff
that we'll be talking about in this
seminar what I want to do this morning
is to begin with a story and my story
basically is that of a colleague of mine
Pervez contry who is a faculty member at
Stanford and who describes himself as a
data parasite and I think it's important
to give you a sense for the kind of art
that Pervez does because I think it
motivates a lot of our concerns about
data and the data lifecycle which well
beginning to later in the hour so
Pradesh is mainly concerned about
functional genomics data
he knows that out there are all kinds of
microarray data that can be very useful
in understanding how genes get turned on
and turned off in response to various
magnetic biological signals and he knows
that all of the data that corresponds to
those kinds of experiments that are at
least performed in the United States are
available to the NCBI is gene expression
omnibus or geo go out to geo and in this
large database you will be able to find
information about basically every
microarray experiment that's ever been
done and prevention goes out to geo with
the express desire to understand what he
can learn from the data that had been
collected by other investigators and
deposited in the geo data repository so
contry basically is billing his career
about studying other people's data and
basically what that means is looking at
the publicly available data that are out
there on the web in order to understand
one of the different kinds of
experimental conditions that
investigators are considering what kind
of real-world energy needed
heterogeneity might might enter into
their data sets and recognize and you
can do all this without having to
perform his own experiments and so
there's really no experimental cost at
least in terms of the initial data
collection he can get human samples and
he doesn't have to worry about IRB
approval because that's already been
done and what country has done is to
create a pipeline that allows him to
search for datasets in geo
to look for genomic signals to confirm
those signals and validation data sense
and then to confirm what he sees in this
mature Lucinda generally selves in a
test set and then to confirm those
signals in validation data sets and what
this allows him to do is to see if he
can infer information from existing
microwave studies that may not have been
considered by the investigators who did
those studies in the first place
but where he can make discoveries on the
existing data sets without ever had me
to perform an initial experiment as for
the outline of that flow of work is
shown on the right-hand side of this
slide and he's demonstrated the value of
this approach and a wide range of areas
one that's gotten a lot of press lately
is that a diagnosis of sepsis
so sepsis is basically a response to
infection in the body that can be very
difficult to detect at first it can be
confused with lots of other common kinds
of abnormalities that occur in
hospitalized patients usually its
response to infection of the blood but
there could be lots of non-infectious
causes of inflammation that can look a
lot like sepsis as well and so coming up
with this diagnosis is obviously
critical because unless you make this
diagnosis and treat the underlying
infection patients die and what
prevention has done is to go out to geo
the gene expression omnibus looking at
functional genomics data with a clinical
question are there changes in gene
expression that can predict the advent
of sepsis and professions going out
there found some sample data some
validation data looking at his initial
samples he had looked at nine cohorts
with 663 samples identified candidate
genes and two candidate genes that might
be suggestive of the onset of sepsis and
he validated eleven genes which showed
to be important both in his test set and
his Dennis and his validation set and
when he looks at those genes
he shows really phenomenal ROC curves
that showed that these genes are very
very sensitive
it turned on when sepsis is imminent and
he can show an effect where with the
advent of sepsis with each passing day
those genes get turned on to even
greater degrees I'm not going to go into
the details of Pradesh's numbers but
they're just absolutely exciting because
this is a way of trying to identify a
new way of diagnosing a medical
condition but purely on the basis of
other people's data stored in a public
repository and Prevention's taking this
approach and applied it to not only did
the diagnosis of incipient sepsis but
also the diagnosis of tuberculosis and
distinguishing active TB from disease
that is burned out which is actually
very hard to do clinically
distinguishing viral respiratory
infection from bacterial respiratory
infection another very important
clinical challenge that usually results
in a lot of overmedication
patients with antibiotics that can be
avoided if one knows that something is
viable from the beginning use the same
approach to identify rejection of organ
transplants another difficult diagnostic
problem in clinical medicine all of
these challenges are really tough to do
clinically but can be addressed easily
by looking at changes in gene expression
and the most exciting thing about this
whole adventure that Prevention has been
undergoing is that he's never trusted my
pet he's never had to kill a mouse he's
never actually had to do the experiments
that lead to those data because the
people who have done the experiments
have been very cognizant of what's
needed in order to make their data not
only valuable for the experiments that
they are planning but also valuable for
the future of scientific work so you can
be a data parasite like prevention
contry only if the data that you might
want to find are in some public
repository that are findable through
some sort of a search facility that you
can find in some rich and some standard
format that you can Carson and compute
with and most important is the data
themselves are self describing so that
you know how to make sense of the data
they're not just a bunch of columns of
information but rather they actually can
describe themselves to understand what
the columns mean and you can
since those columns and that the product
of careful planning organization and
stewardship and they're basically
created in a way where the data
themselves are intended to be reused at
to outlive the experiment which they
were collected and I guess that's the
key thing because in the old school of
thought we might think of data as being
the sign effects of our experiment we
publish our paper and the paper that we
publish is a result of our research and
I think currently the tide is shifting
and we're thinking about the data
themselves as being the output of our
investigation and we think about data as
having a lifecycle a lifecycle that
starts with the idea of planning what
we're going to do with the data
collecting the data performing quality
assurance on the data describing those
data so that we understand what the data
are about preserving them in an archive
making sure that it's possible for other
people to discover those data to
integrate those data with other data
that they might have available to
perform new kinds of analyses that might
lead to new insights that might cause us
to do new kinds of experiments which
themselves will require us to begin this
lifecycle again to plan experiments to
collect data to perform QA and so on
we've moved into a one into a world
basically where the experiment begins
not with the definition of the protocol
that we're going to follow as much as
the definition of the plan for data
management that will be necessary in
order to perform the protocol and make
sure that the data themselves outlive
the experiment that we're planning and
so what I want to do is going to follow
us I want us to follow this data
lifecycle and get a sense what these
various steps are emphasizing that each
one of these steps is going to be the
subject of a talk you'll hear about
later in this colloquium series let me
start by saying that one begins with
plans and the plans the data management
plans that guide our work basically are
required now by almost every funding
agency because of executive orders the
NIH if you have a project that in
more than $500,000 of direct costs every
year you must have a data management
plan if you deal with genomic sequence
data then you must have a data
management plan and frankly if you're
smart you're going to have a data
management plan because the data
management plan saved lots of time and
effort down the road by making sure we
know what we're going to do with the
data we'll get them most important they
enhance the durability and the long term
value of the data so that investigators
like prevent can find these data later
and identify even new kinds of
inferences that can come from those data
as I said they're required by sponsors
unfortunately although the data plans
are required there are almost never
reviewed issac as a consequence of peer
review at least at this point that may
change but right now the requirement is
that the data plan exists not
necessarily that it satisfied the
criteria of peer review but it's there
and frankly in the best projects the
data plan is not created once at the
start but rather is revisited and
updated throughout the projects so that
we can make sure that we're dealing with
data appropriately that data plan
requires us to be thinking about what is
the project they're actually doing what
are the existing data that may already
be available that we want to be able to
consider in our experiments what are the
new data that we're going to be cheating
generating one of the methods and the
instruments for the data collection oh
if we collect the data how do we
organize them what is the data storage
format what are the structures what what
is that what is the mechanism by which
we're going to store the data what
permissions do we need to allow people
to access the data are we gonna back up
the data hopefully how often we back up
and how what kind of data scrubbing or
Quality Assurance do we anticipate what
are the administrative legal and ethical
concerns are we dealing with human
subjects data how we're going to protect
human subjects how do we archive and
publish our data what are the
responsibilities and dual-use the
various project members who are going to
be contributing to the data and what are
the costs and resources that we need to
do this experiment lots of stuff it's a
little bit daunting the good news is
that there are open source tools that
are readily
would called EMP tool that almost all
research universities seem to be using
and there are lots of easy ways for
basically using templates to create data
management plans and to make sure that
they're available with the proposals
that we submit even before we begin to
do experimentation and at the same time
because these are available and easily
editable they allow us to make sure that
our management plans evolve as we
recognize additional complications as
the s experiments get performed so let
me collect the data and collecting the
data you know it can be done in a
gazillion different ways because frankly
there are a gazillion kinds of data and
so our data management plan provides the
guidance that allows us to understand
how to deal with the data that we're
collecting are those data going to be
coming from laboratory observations are
they going to be coming directly from
instrument so they come in from surveys
that we may administer to human subjects
are they coming from
continuous electronic signals are they
coming from discrete values such as
microarray chips I mean all kinds of
data are used in biomedicine and we have
to understand how to get them in one
place
so that we can begin to analyze them the
data may also not be coming from de novo
experimentation but as I showed in the
case of the kind of work that urban
country does they may come from online
repositories so our collection of data
may not come from direct experimentation
but from gathering data from the
publicly available datasets that other
investigators have put online and
sometimes we're dealing with meta
analyses or systematic reviews we may be
getting data not from actual datasets
but from other publications engines
amassing the publication's themselves in
order to perform our work now on
September 30th we're going to have a
talk on data curation by Pascal cadet on
November 4th oh we're here about data
warehousing from Jaden baru so be
prepared for all kinds of talks coming
up that will deal with these kinds of
aspects of the data lifecycle
insurance is sort of the next step in
the in that lifecycle sometimes people
call it data scrubbing and it is
actually a science in and of itself
trakone will give a talk on this on
December 2nd we'll talk about how to
double check the values of data there in
my hand how to identify data that may
have quality problems that need to get
flagged how we can use statistics to
understand where we might have data
outliers how we can identify what data
might be impossible how we can identify
missing data and maybe correct the
values for for missing data or a new
that cube replacements how to deal with
those outliers basically there's a whole
science if you will to dealing with the
fact that our data are usually full of
errors and before we actually make data
publicly available and apply our own
investigative techniques those data
there are things that we need to do in
order to make sure that the data are
going to meet our expectations and be
reliable for our own use so we plan our
data over all our data that it did event
management overall we collected data
from quality assurance and scrubbing and
then we're in a situation where we need
to describe the data so we can't just
have data and stick it in a drawer we
have to be able to recognize that we
need metadata and as Jason Scott says
maybe metadata is a love note to the
future is our ability to describe data
so that down the road we can figure out
what we did and we can make sure that
other people who may want to think about
data or think about our data know what
is in the data and how to how to make
sense of those data so metadata
described lots and lots of different
things they describe the digital content
so one of the the actual properties of
the files themselves that store the data
they provide a mechanism for clarifying
who are the investigators and who are
the stakeholders who care about this
data what is the scientific content so
basically why was the experiment done
what were the data they're actually
collected what were the methods that
were applying what instruments were used
to acquire the data
not only the kind of instrument but
actually what the fiscal Israel what
actual serial number was used from it
went through what was the serial number
of the instrument used when and where
were the data collected and basically
one of the parameters of the date a lot
lots of stuff these I should mention
that this list of metadata attributes
comes from the data one primer on data
management which i think is great I give
that as a reference at the end of this
talk and also let you know that on
October 21st Susana Sansone from Oxford
is going to give a talk on metadata and
metadata standards and I think that talk
will be will really be very very helpful
now I mentioned that not only do you
want to understand the experiment in the
metadata we want to understand the
parameters of the data that may seem
pretty trivial but in fact there's lots
of evidence that shows that when we
don't do that we get into really big
trouble
We certainly have good examples where
you have trouble making sense of
biomedical data I think one of the best
anecdotes is what happened in 1998 but
we sent the Mars climate orbiter to Mars
it's a great anecdote on an especially
unfortunate anecdote because it really
was a 328 million dollar disaster as
those of you who may remember this this
is misadventure the manufacturers of the
satellite did their work correctly and
follow the specifications and manage all
their data using the metric system but
when NASA sent data up to the Mars
climate orbiter those data were sent in
the English system and suddenly getting
data in foot-pounds was something that
really threw off the satellite and it it
crashed into the Martian surface and the
idea that NASA would not recognize that
there need to be unique inversion
without obviously rather embarrassing
and probably some provides one of the
best examples of why not only does our
metadata need to describe what
experiments we did but also provide the
data specific information that allows us
to understand what it is that well how I
did are actually represented what those
mysterious units are so
the metadata about the parameters will
include how each parameter is measured
or produced what its units of measure
are the formats used in the data said
the precision accuracy and uncertainty
who is which the data values are
represented definitions and any codes
that are used what kinds of quality
assurance was performed on the data
known problems that can limit the data
use and and how to cite the data set
these are all things of course that we
would like our metadata to say and I
guess one thing that I should be making
very clear is that we often actually we
usually don't have metadata that
describes information and at any of this
level of detail and of course one of the
goals of research and data science is to
make it easier and better for us to be
able to make sure that our data are
described at the right level of detail
so if we go to the gene expression
omnibus this is the place where we store
all the DNA microarray data that for
example prevents country accesses one of
the things that was very clear is that
there is a template for how data and geo
need to be represented in the database
and this isn't just any old template
created by NCBI basically the framework
for representing gene expression data in
geo stems from a description that is now
almost 16 years old called the minimum
information standard about a microarray
experiment or Miami and Miami basically
represents the work of a community of
investigators who got together and
recognized that people were storing
microarray data online but they were
doing it in a rather ad hoc fashion and
it was often impossible to look at the
guideline data and understand how to
make sense of the data that was stored
there and the community said look we're
not waiting for some publisher or some
sponsor to force this on us we want to
get together and come up with a minimal
set of information components that need
to be described in order for us to
understand what someone else may have
done with the gene microarray and that
means basically understand
with Roy data our how the processing was
done how the sample was annotated and
all the kinds of features that are
critical in order to make sense of these
kinds of data and what's really very
exciting is not only has the microwave
community created this kind of a
standard but lots of other groups have
if you go to bio sharing org which is a
necessity we'll be talking about on
October 21st you can find the Miami
description online and a way of
beginning a good reference for what
Miami looks like and knowing how to use
Miami destroyed microwave information
but what's great by our sharing has
information on hundreds of different
kinds of biomedical experiments and so
going to by a sharing will allow you to
find out information about how to
represent metadata and a whole variety
of community blast approaches and it's
really very exciting that that I think
the biomedical community is getting
together and articulating these kinds of
frameworks and you'll hear a lot more
about this in October when Susana cancer
talk and just to give a little bit of
plug to my own work I should say and the
seeder project that Phil mentioned what
we're doing in cedar is developing
computational methods for taking these
kinds of standardized metadata templates
that are already being promulgated by
the community and putting them in a
computational form that makes it really
easy we hope for investigators to fill
out these checklists and their templates
and to create the kinds of robust and
complete metadata that we think are
going to be really really important in
order to ensure that the information
that is stored in public repositories
provides enough description so that
people can find what they need and put
it to use now you'll notice when we look
at metadata templates with templates
like this cell line template from the
links project that's in cedar there are
lots of blanks to get filled in and one
nominally could fill on these blanks
just by typing in the text of any kind
but one of the things that I think is
really important for creating metadata
and something that the data science
community recognized
increasingly is what we really want to
do is fill in those blanks with terms
from standardized terminologies or
oncology's I don't have time this
morning to talk about ontology is in any
detail know that on October 7th Michel
de Montaigne is going to give a whole
talk on ontology this slide we showed
you a little snippet from the National
Cancer Institute thesaurus is one
ontology that's become become very
important for cancer biology and all of
these hundreds of ontology that are
available in biomedicine provide
controlled terms that make it possible
for investigators to fill in blanks
using terms that are precise that have
agreed upon meanings and basically will
be recognized for what for those
meanings when people process the kinds
of metadata descriptions that we need in
order to access metadata online so we've
planned our data management we collected
our data we perform Quality Assurance
we've described our our data using
templates that ontology is now we have
to preserve the data we have to put the
data on our own servers so to speak in
order to be able to use those data for
our own analyses and ultimately we want
to be able to preserve those data for
the future so that others can access our
data make sense of those data and do the
kinds of experiments that country does
you would think putting data on a disk
is not all that hard you would think
that knowing how to put data in a form
where people can access it in a few days
in a few months or a few years is not
that difficult but actually requires a
lot of planning and a lot of thought and
perhaps we know back to the NASA example
sometimes it's fun to pick on NASA but
certainly as someone who is very
captivated myself by the space program
and got so excited by what NASA was
doing in the 1960s and 1970s one of the
more famous stories to come out of that
that era concerns the fact that much of
what came out of the Apollo program was
captured in a variety of data formats
ranging from numerical data sets to
video probably the video that we all
remember the most is a video of Neil
Armstrong when he first set foot on the
moon
many of us watch these videos was just
absolute amazement to think that people
were sending on the lunar surface what
was interesting is that around 2006
there was suddenly a recognition that
when you look at the still photos of
people in Mission Control watching the
astronauts on the lunar surface at least
the Apollo 11 mission photos the videos
weren't nearly this grainy and weren't
nearly this bad and in fact when you
look at the stills you see that in
real-time Mission Control was seeing
phenomenal photos that were taken from
the video available from the lunar
surface whereas those of us watching on
TV saw these kinds of blurry images and
there was a great revelation that took
place in Australia where the original
signals from the moon were collected in
the Apollo 11 mission and this article
which appeared in The Sydney Morning
Herald on October 7 2006 describes what
it was presented as one giant blunder
for mankind because basically what
happened in 1969 was that the really
high density video image that came from
the lunar surface was stored in a
particular format they've been saved on
magnetic tape what the rest of us saw
because that particular format was not
something that could be broadcast
internationally was a monitor that was
displaying the high quality image coming
from the moon that was being filmed by a
standard video camera so that the signal
could be sent up in NTSC formats the
rest of the broadcast world and and is
actually a video of that NTSC that we
have preserved and the original high
quality video Neil Armstrong stepping
onto the moon was stored on a videotape
that sounds great until you hear that
sometime in the 1970s to realize that it
needed some more videotape and recorded
over the original videotapes that have
high-quality transmission stored on it
and this is sort of a really sad story
failing to have a data management plan
failing to recognize that this video
might have lasting value to the to
humanity and that an expedient need to
have a new new Tait recopies a new data
on led to the loss of something which I
think most people would view as
extremely important and so it's just
sort of a way of sort of making us all
remember that media are critical that
the media that we use today to store our
data may not be the media that we're
using in 10 or 15 years I think I think
we've always who have been around long
enough thinking about what kinds of data
storage we had in the 1970s and 1980s
that's pretty clear and there's also the
issue of just what people are called bit
rot that over time sometimes the way in
which we store data even digitally leads
to loss of information and we have to
recognize that we copies and we need
backups and the good news is on
September 30th the Pascal Haddad was
going to be talking about data curation
and I'll talk a lot more some of them
physical problems of storing data and
how to avoid some of these really ugly
things so life cycle involves planning
collection QA does description
preservation and then ultimately our
goal is to discover we want to be able
to find the data that we need not only
for our own experiments but also as
we've discussed already for other
investigators to find our data and
discover new kinds of things from those
data and so the good news is lots of
work is taking place in the biomedical
community in this area we are no longer
stuck in the era and the era of card
catalogs we have all kinds of technology
like the data med a system coming out of
the bio Kennedy community and so the
good news is in the seminar series on
September 16th bill Herschel talked
about general problems of information
retrieval and on September 23 or so Otto
Machado from UCSD I'm sure we'll talk
about data med the tool coming out of
i/o caddy which allows us to access data
and a variety of repositories in a
generic way and to search for data so
that we can access
we need and put the quick data together
in ways which I think will lead to new
kinds of experimental insights and so
the data lifecycle continues to
circulate we want to plan we want to
collect we want to describe and preserve
and discover and integrate and frankly
we're in a stage where we are
recognizing that this like life cycle
just circulates over and over and over
again as data become available online
and we can experiment with this data and
again without either picking up a
pipette we can learn new things about
biomedicine and the I think that the
buzzword that is now permeating of the
community that you'll hear a lot about
in upcoming talks is this notion of
making data fair the idea of that damage
would be findable that it should be
accessible interoperable and reusable
these terms were came out of a workshop
that took place in the Netherlands a
couple years ago and now they're being
adopted widely in the electric community
in Europe the bd2k community in the
United States and this notion of fair
data where it's possible to find data
that may have been created by other
investigators where were the data are
accessible because they're stored in
formats that we understand that we can
parse and let me get interpret that
they're interoperable because we can
relate our data to the data that you
have available online and make sense of
Orion and datasets and we use those data
to create new insights to identify as
country did a genomic signature for
sepsis or genomic signature or active TB
these are the kinds of experiments the
kinds of insights are going to come from
the data that we have online and frankly
are going to increase the effectiveness
of the biomedical Enterprise by orders
of magnitude because not only when we
have the insights that come from the
initial experiments but we're going to
be able to have tons of investigators
who will be looking at existing datasets
and coming up with insights that were
just impossible to make at the time that
the data were originally collected
either because the original
investigators never thought of it
or because in retrospect we understand
more about the world that we may have
understood previously
and allow us to think about new kinds of
analyses we can perform and new kinds of
investigations that's why now 40 50
years later NASA is working really hard
to figure out how in trying to recover
many of the datasets that were created
during the 1960s and stored on media
that can no longer be read because the
kinds of machines that read them no
longer exist because now that we
understand all that we've learned over
the past 40 years
we want to go back to those data and
reinterpret them and that's exactly
what's going to be happening in
biomedicine as we try to go to all data
sets are available and the repositories
that we manage throughout the biomedical
enterprise and start interpreting those
data anew in terms of all the things
that we'll learn in the interim that's a
very exciting part and that's one of the
reasons that having fair data is so
important to us there's also if you will
a dark side that makes air data just as
important and that is the increasing
mistrust that people have had in science
people may remember the famous economist
front-page article that occurred about
two or three years ago discussing the
problems that scientists have in being
able to read
a question ok relating how engine tried
really hard to reproduce the findings
that 1663 landmark papers and cancer
biology and claimed that they only do so
in about six of them when bear tried to
reproduce sixty seven preclinical
studies and said they were successful in
validating the results in only twenty
five percent the the notion that many of
these landmark studies that ultimately
may have been difficult to reproduce
spawn entire fields of investigation
when no one bothering to confirm the
initial results but taken them for
granted and trying to do new experiments
that basically allegedly would build on
those reproducible results and frankly
as many of us know it is the non
reproducible studies that are more
likely to get published in the journal
ten of the highest impact factors
because often those not reproducible
studies frankly I have the most exciting
results even though it may be often
difficult in some cases to reproduce and
of course this is a problem that's
gotten a lot of hand-wringing lots of
people talk about it has lots of causes
and some of them are pretty trivial
sometimes there's not a mystical power
in the study sometimes there's an art
form in conducting experiments of the
metadata themselves don't capture all
that information there's alternatives to
publish earlier or frankly prematurely
rarely there's fraud but really I think
for many of us we have a problem where
we have a system which traditionally has
not made it easy or rewarding for
investigators to replicate the results
of other researchers and we have a
culture that is only now recognizing the
importance of data preservation
description and we exploration but as we
pay more attention to the data lifecycle
as we think about how we can use other
people's data how we can learn from
others people's data why it's important
to revalidate other people's data I
honestly believe that the world is going
to change and at a minimum we're going
to see science moving
to a situation where we have even more
open online access to experimental data
sets where there's an emphasis on
annotation of online data sense with
adequate metadata that not only will be
trying to have the minimal information
about data available online but I think
ultimately we're going to see so much
high quality metadata online that the
online data may well record
well be just as useful as the journal
publication understanding what
scientists have done and how to make
sense of their work there was increasing
emphasis on the use of ontology is to be
able to annotate metadata in a
reproducible way and ultimately as
systems like data med lead to better
search but for experimental results
we're going to be able to find the data
that we need and analyze them better no
and fundamentally what we're moving
toward is a world where there's much
more concern about data stewardship and
we recognize that the lifecycle is
really where we're at where where it
said where we need to be focusing our
attention so ultimately we're thinking
about a revolution in the way we talk
about science um that we talk about data
we're gonna be thinking about a world
where invariably
data are going to be coming at us with
increasing volume velocity and variety
and as a consequence the kinds of
experiments that we do and the way that
we manage our data are going to require
lots of new computational approaches new
approaches that people are working on
right now and that you'll learn about in
this seminar series we're recognizing
that because data need to be validated
and reinterpreted and we explored
investigators will no longer think of
data as the side effect or the end
product that allows them to come up with
the real result of the research the
scientific paper but rather to treat the
data as the actual purpose of the work
and the data as the endpoint that is
complemented by the scientific paper but
that also is going to provide the basis
for future experimentation by a whole
cadre of investigators who may not even
have been born yet
and with a recognition that data should
be fair findable accessible
interoperable and reusable investigators
what begins a need to plan for data
management in much more comprehensive
ways before they even begin their
experiments during their experiments as
conditions change and even after their
experiments as they recognize that there
may be better ways to make the data more
publicly available so that other
investigators can take advantage of the
kinds of data that are being produced in
the biomedical Enterprise so there's a
lifecycle that I've mentioned and if you
think about the lifecycle not only does
this provide a good framework for
thinking about how data are collected
and managed and used and discovered and
form the and used to form the basis of
new experimentation but basically what I
think captures all the main high points
of data science that you'll hear about
in this lecture series and so the most
important thing I can leave you with is
that coming up are going to be some
really fantastic talks by some really
great people and I hope that what I've
said today will inspire you to tune in
every week and hear about what is what's
going on on the cutting edge of data
science and biomedicine and let me leave
you with a couple references that I
think I found really useful and thinking
about some of the things I've talked
about this morning and hopefully you'll
find diamo as you think about how you're
going to be taking advantage of data
management planning thinking about the
data lifecycle and putting it to use in
your own work let me stop there and
they'll soon have some time for some
questions perhaps so thank you mark
wonderful you they have a great overview
of what we will see coming up and I know
I for one am really looking forward to
this I think if there are any questions
we need to have them by the chat because
everyone well done in the silent mode so
if you do have a question please just
write it in the chat box on the right
hand side of the control panel or on
your control panel wherever it is and
dr. Mason might have a time for a couple
to take a couple of questions
so there was one that came up earlier in
the under the question box and it's
about their data and interoperability
and it says given the challenges with
legacy data interoperability for example
electronic health record limitations as
far as exchanging data will this lecture
our future lecture discuss or can you
discuss how to reconcile the need for
open fair data and the underlying and
interoperability challenges
still there that did I get it I think
you did get muted for for a bit oh my
back
you are back now they'll mark okay I
won't take it personally that was a
great question and it's more than I can
answer in a couple of minutes but I
think there are problems that you point
out because the way that we do
experiments change over time sometimes I
mean we talk about microdata being
reexamine obviously the kinds of chips
that people use change over time to
being able to go back and make sense of
some of the very oldest technology is
always challenging a lot of the
challenges occur because the way we
think about the world changes so I
mentioned ontology x' as being an
important way to allow for
interoperability among heterogeneous
data sets but our ontology themselves
change over time we know for example the
data that were analyzed with old
versions of the gene ontology will get
results that are different from data
they're analyzed with new versions of
the gene ontology and so I don't want to
say that we have a panacea for dealing
with change over time in these
experimental data sets but we do have
real opportunity for a really exciting
research in how to reconcile ontology is
it change over time how to ensure that
data have sufficient annotation that
would go back and reconstruct what are
all the assumptions that may be relevant
trying to integrate data that were
created in debt at different points in
time under different circumstances and
recognizing that it's not just a matter
of mixing and matching datasets but
there really is a science to being able
to enumerate what are the assumptions
behind data and to be able to reconcile
for those assumptions in Stata get
integrated thanks there are quite a few
other questions under the the question
box one of them that I see on the very
bottom is do you think that the state of
lifecycle applies to all kinds of data
other than
biomechanical data yes and I can say
that my first the first reference that
you see on the screen now is one from
the data one community which is
concerned with Earth Sciences and I
think they represented a different kind
of community but have exactly the same
kinds of data needs and recognize
exactly the same problems I think that
the issues that we're talking about
relate to all of science and I think
they lost result relate to data that are
not necessarily created through
controlled experimentation
I think they relate to observational
studies as much as they do
interventional studies I think they
relate to signal data that are acquired
opportunistically and I think to a
certain degree they relate to the kind
of data we get from the EHRs so I think
in a sense all of these issues are
relevant and I think we're going to be
seeing persistence of data in all these
forms and we explore a ssin of those
data from all those various sources in
the future okay I think we have time for
maybe one more question there's one here
about data sharing and it says that
there has been much progress in sharing
molecular data but there are challenges
to clinical data particularly challenges
around privacy consent and other issues
and that investigators are hesitant to
share the data do you foresee directions
for tackling these challenges well I
think that one of the biggest challenges
in data sharing is the WI IFM problem
that's that's not a radio station that's
what's in it for me and I think
investigators need to be able to
understand that by making their data
public not only will they learn more
because other people may have insights
that they can contribute back but also I
think it's poor part of the scientific
enterprise and I think one of the things
that is changing is a recognition that
science doesn't stop with publication of
a bunch of prose but with the
opportunity of others and the community
at large to be able to look at data sets
that said not only will people I hope
act altruistic Allah but clearly funders
are thinking about doing what they can
to ensure that the data are made
available and the basic sentiment is
that data that are collected as a
consequence of public investment and
research belong to the public and
therefore need to be made available that
is obviously going to be different in
the case of EHR data which have a
different different value but at the
same time I think patients who recognize
that the learning health system as a
model is going to be making medical care
better and more precise in the future
also recognize that they may want to
make their data available even if their
providers may not because those data
will ensure that the care of future
patients any more refined and so I think
a lot of this that depends on cultural
change and the recognition among
investigators that data sharing is
important and also when it comes to
clinical data at recognition on the part
of patients that they can help humanity
by making their data they almost well so
thank you so much mark I think the if
Jack would like to say the last few
words I am Not sure they are able to I
think they're do cut out but if and
unless they want to jump on I think we
should just say thank you to our speaker
which I think everyone was giving you a
silent applause right now mark and but
I've been also thank you to everyone who
joined in sorry about the slow start
this morning we will be sending out
again the new URL and I particularly
want to thank the training Coordination
Center for at the last minute switching
over to a service that will accommodate
all all of us so thank you very much and
I hope that you all tune in in the next
in the upcoming weeks because we have a
great program ahead of us by now